Hey it's Joey and welcome to Better Ideas.
You've probably heard the news - cold showers
are the secret to unlocking your inner potential
and giving you super powers beyond your wildest
dreams.
Now, there are a ton of YouTube videos and
articles online that you can find that get
into the nitty-gritty of exactly what cold
showers do to you physiologically but what
I'm more interested in is what they do to
you mentally.
I actually gave a speech about cold showers
last semester for a public speaking class.
Joey: "It's almost like your primal brain
thinks you're being tossed into a river from
your slumber or something - you're fighting
for your life basically."
I talked about the physiological benefits
as well as my own experience with the 30 day
cold shower challenge.
Now before we dive into what I find is the
most fascinating part, which is the mental
benefit of cold showers, let's just do a quick
review of the physical benefits, in case you're
uninitiated.
Medical Daily says, "cold shower refined skin
and hair and rehydrates it."
Makes sense, because, I mean I don't know
if you've ever taken a really really hot,
long, steamy shower before - you probably
have if you're human - often your hair gets
really dried out and your skin starts to ash
or you get ashy elbows or something.
Anyways, cold showers will stop that.
The Art of Manliness says that according to
a study done by the Thrombosis Research Centre
back in 1993, individuals who took daily cold
showers saw an increase in the number of virus-fighting
white blood cells compared to individuals
who took hot showers.
Cool stuff.
Still not the coolest part, though.
LifeHack says that a third benefit is that
it stimulates brown fat, which is the good
fat in your body, apparently that a lot of
people don't know about.
So, the fat that you're trying to get rid
of is called yellow fat, and it's the bad,
undesirable fat that usually collects around
your waistline and your tummy.
Tummy...
Stomach.
Brown fat helps to eat away at bad or yellow
fat.
So basically, cold showers stimulate weight-loss,
which is awesome.
Now there are a ton of other benefits, that
people claim cold showers are responsible
for, like increased fertility in men, increased
testosterone in men... a lot of "Men Benefits".
and mitigating symptoms of depressions.
Now all these benefits sound like enough reason
to take a cold shower right now, and they
probably are, but I find - the coolest part
about cold showers is what they do to you
as a person.
Which kinda sounds like fluffy stuff, but
let me break it down for you: First of all,
going back to the concept of The Flinch, which
I talked about in an earlier video, I'll put
the link in the description - cold showers
are extremely uncomfortable.
Even the mere thought of having to take one
makes you uncomfortable.
Despite the fact that you have absolutely
nothing to lose except your comfort, and all
those benefits to gain.
Now think about all the things that you're
really proud of in life - the things that
you put blood, sweat, and tears into achieving.
How many hours of discomfort did you put into
achieving those things?
But standing here in the present day, aren't
you glad you went through that anyways?
Because the pain is gone now - and all that's
remaining is the result of your discomfort,
hard work, and perseverance.
So in a way, cold showers are the ultimate
brain hack, and it forces you right off the
get-go to get into a no pain, no gain mentality.
It forces you to scare away the flinch right
when you wake up, so that when it comes time
to do schoolwork, laundry, fill out your taxes
- it's absolutely nothing - you'll just go
and do it - there is no flinch anymore - you've
scared it away.
All of these little tasks that you usually
don't end up doing seem like nothing in comparison
to the cold shower you took that morning.
You've conditioned yourself to be comfortable
with the uncomfortable - and you've shifted
your brain's mentaility from instant gratification
and momentary pleasure to long-term gain,
and real, substantial benefit - and that's
why cold showers are so powerful.
So I challenge you - go take a cold shower
today.
It'll suck, but that's entirely the point.
If you liked this video and want to see me
make more, hit that subscribe button down
below.
I love seeing new subscriptions - I also like
seeing your comments, so if you comment I
will probably respond to it - and it not,
I will like it, and I just will appreciate
it in general.
Also follow me on Twitter @BetterIdeasTV and
right now we're in and around 100 subcribers
so once we hit 250 subscribers, I'll be doing
a random giveaway - I don't know what that
item will be yet but all you need to do to
enter is hit that subscribe button down below
- and you'll be automatically registered.
Thanks for watching and we'll catch you in
the next video.